here we have the story from the Daily
Mail they are not your kids DeSantis and
musk slam White House for Pride tweet
celebrating lgbtq uh Qi community and
quote our kids that are part of it in
the post it says these are our kids not
somebody else's kids they're all our
kids that is unbelievable I shouldn't
say it's unbelievable it's predictable
but that is because they're just openly
is sayify a part loud it's it's obvious
because they're not Liberals are not
having kids they're aborting their kids
and in many instances now they are
sterilizing or increasing the the
likelihood of sterilization of these
kids but what kind of creep says that
right who knows that their political
faction doesn't have voters yes but this
is my point they're not just saying it
you're right they're acting on it but if
if anyone else like if somebody came up
to you in public and said those aren't
your kids those are our kids how would
you respond to them I would show them a
picture of the Communist meme with Drake
pointing to go like this to my kids and
then pointing to our kids I would call
the police
yeah someone said your kids are mine
yeah and calling 9-1-1 okay our kids are
mine I would I'm not sure if I'm able to
stay on air what the I would ask I would
ask but I would ask if they live in a
house made of candy they're passing
legislation in all sorts of blue states
to make this a reality right where they
can take California away from you if you
don't agree that your girl is a boy that
was California well it's a lot of
something through the House of
Representatives I think into their
Senate hasn't gone through the state
house it's now Advanced to their state
senate in California
and they're saying that if you don't
affirm your child that uh they could
they could restrict visitation or take
custody of your kids yeah they consider
it child abuse they're already a
sanctuary state so that
if there's a custody dispute going on in
Texas for example and this mom wants to
transition the kid she can take the kid
to California and California will now
ignore all court orders subpoena's
arrest warrants or custody agreements so
that this job can be transitioned or a
runaway as well so they'll hide the
runaway from the parents and they won't
return them home so they'll ignore the
laws of the home state which should
violate the constitution this needs to
be challenged and this is this this is
reminiscent to me of the American Civil
War when they had The Runaways I think
with the Runaway Slave Act you had uh
states in the north saying that we will
absolutely not abide by these uh by this
law and the South saying then why are we
a part of this Union southern states
were like if we have a law then and you
don't follow it what's the point now the
circumstances of course are different
the moral questions are different I'm
wondering what the major Catalyst will
be maybe it's abortion abortion seems to
be a direct 14th Amendment uh question
in this country and uh a 14th Amendment
violation in most regards so I wonder if
that'll be the Catalyst but I also kind
of think
you know I don't know if the uh
transgender kid stuff will be the
Catalyst and it's because I listened to
audio from Matt Walsh of a father saying
they took his kid away and we're putting
her on cross-sex hormones
and it's like he's upset about it and he
doesn't want it to happen but that's the
extent of the action that he's taking
right I feel like when it came to John
Brown when it came to slavery you had
active Conflict for a decade of people
killing each other over the stuff that
you don't really have right now in any
of these social issues yeah I well I
think there's a few so I hear what
you're saying about this not necessarily
being a potential Catalyst for massive
conflict but I also think that when
you're talking about people's children
it's just a question of how many kids
you do this to before somebody gets
violent it's going to happen you're
right they I guess they haven't landed
on those people who are going to respond
violently to them but it they will
eventually no no no no no I'm not
talking about uh civilians talking about
government
you're talking about like at the state
level at what point do does the federal
government or law enforcement say
you must return the child under the code
of the law and then California says no
and then troops will have to be sent to
California to enforce the law
when when where you know so I you know
people give out for all sorts of things
and we definitely don't want to happen
we need we we want civility we want
peace and at this point I think violence
actually just empowers them because it
terrifies people and they're able to use
terrorism as a weapon yeah I'm saying
like at what point does Texas say we we
we are demanding the return of this
man's child to California and California
says we're not going to answer your
subpoena like you said they're gonna
they're gonna ignore subpoena's warrants
Etc
at what point does is how can there be
an intervention does Texas then petition
the federal government saying we need
federal assistance to to enforce these
laws between states what will likely
occur I'd imagine is a lawsuit under
original jurisdiction going to the
Supreme Court the Supreme Court might
just reject it outright and say we're
not going to listen to this and then
you're going to have Texas be like we're
sending the Rangers we're going to send
law enforcement to California to
retrieve this man's child because we
have the force of law behind us and
these people have committed crimes
California is now harboring criminals
what point do states actually send law
enforcement after each other yeah that's
a good question I've how does this all
go how does society go so this is a big
question
because it seems we're so divided almost
irreparably so
and each political party
really Stoke division the media of
course Stokes division
it almost seems irreparable I think
we need an extremely strong and truthful
and compassionate leader who can unite
but that's almost impossible as well
with this social media age but
I'm an eternal optimist and I do think
it's possible but I don't really see
that person Trump winning
see you later
there's no uniting there's only weeding
out corruption
so
was reconstruction after the Civil War
in the United States unit uniting the
country
now you can argue it was but it was
brutal I mean getting rid of slavery I
think was Paramount and it was good that
it was done
but if you hear the stories about how
the Civil War went down what the north
was doing in the south I mean it's
brutality it's Untold I mean it's it's
it's horrifying Sherman's March to the
Sea the ransacking of Civilian property
the destruction of everything in his in
in in his path just because they're like
we're going to win and we're gonna
destroy it it's scorched Earth
if Donald Trump gets elected
and these states openly defy the federal
government
insurrection
he will then cite everything they've
said about January 6 and Insurrection as
his justification for sending the troops
in to enforce the law in these
jurisdictions
as as the federal government dictates
now the funny thing is the right who is
currently saying we want smaller
government the government's oppressive
will find themselves behind a more
oppressive government what worries me is
is that the Trojan Horse to get
federalized a federalized United States
in that the federal government now is
local law enforcement right we've talked
about this during uh the Summer of Love
riots
we don't want the federal government to
be local law enforcement we want states
to have their own jurisdictions
especially when it comes to things like
Roe v Wade the states have the rights to
decide what their laws are
if California is allowing the kidnapping
of children and they will defy subpoenas
and the rule of law outright because
they assert that their their morals
their legal code supersedes anyone
else's then the only option is for
federal law enforcement to intervene to
uphold these laws if Texas issues to
subpoena the federal government says
like we're going to have to make sure
you you can't do these things so let's
talk about Portland because Portland is
to a certain degree a lawless Society
police have orders to stand down
if antifa are committing violent
assaults against people
now for me we cannot live in a society
like that we cannot allow crazy mentally
Disturbed anarchists to determine how
our societies run but this is how it's
being run in Portland so recently I went
to Portland State University stood
outside
with my signs with Peter begosian Dr
Peter Goshen and the incredible James
klug I don't know if you know him yeah
of course he's amazing yeah
dudes a pro but we specifically went
there because
that's the one place the one place in
the Amer in the United States of America
I was a little afraid to go to and you
cannot let fear stop you from doing
anything so we went there we planned it
out we didn't announce when we were
going beforehand because of course
antifa will then have time to mobilize
because you can get killed there but we
went there in the morning we stayed for
a few hours got amazing footage and we
left and I think we showed people that
we don't need to let these anarchists
tell us where and when we can't have
conversations because they're not
anarchists but why doesn't the federal
government move in there well so just to
clarify they're not they're not
anarchists they're they're hardcore
authoritarians and communists right yeah
like well they think yeah they think
they're Communists put them in an actual
communist system and they'll revolve
they'll lie to you and tell you they're
anarchists because the idea Anarchy
literally means uh lacking or without
Authority that's how they lie to you
they come to you and say we don't want
to be in charge we're anarchists we
don't we think there shouldn't be a big
government by the way do as we say or
else that's they're tankies they're
commies they're authoritarians all the
way but it comes from the mayor and the
governor there this lawlessness so do
you think the federal government should
intervene to restore the rule of law yes
I don't disagree but I also think that
can lead down a dark path when you have
people who live in California and say
these are our rules these are the laws
that we've passed and now the federal
government comes in and with national
Guardsmen patrolling neighborhoods
military police and federal law
enforcement Federal uh I guess they'd be
civilian law enforcement
telling people that those laws don't
matter anymore that that they're the way
they vote it doesn't matter imagine the
inverse but it's going to be a state in
this Union you have to abide by
some Collective Agreement but they have
their own within their states right they
keep voting for this they're celebrating
Daniel Petty being Penny being indicted
imagine the inverse Joe Biden sending
National Guard into Oklahoma to enforce
abortion at any point saying your laws
violate National order so we are going
to enforce like the the point is you may
think you're right certainly we here on
this show have our own opinions uh and I
think we are right
but if you zoom out and look at the
picture holistically you can simply say
faction a faction B and what powers can
they wield and if we assert that we are
right so we should be able to go into
their state to enforce our rules on them
regardless of how they voted they would
assert the same right and then we just
hope that we win yeah I look I
understand there's a lot to this and
it's not just I'm not saying we
shouldn't I'm saying Trump should get
elected and Trump should go in I mean
federal law and and supersede these
governments they're violating the law in
Oregon it's not like they're following
their own rules they're violating the
law and no one is doing anything
to bring these criminals to Justice they
won't even stop them committing the
crimes they won't even stop them
assaulting people when the assaults are
happening the police will just stand and
watch it they'll arrest you if you stop
the assault there's a there's a video of
cops and they'll arrest me for getting
assaulted yeah yeah there's a guy being
threatened by a bunch of antifa with
weapons and the cops run up and grab and
arrest the victim it happens all the
time and then they apologize to antifa
saying sorry about that yeah
so yes I think that uh you know I'm not
an anarchist I'm not a uh Big L
libertarian Eileen libertine on most
issues but I believe the big questions
about how government is supposed to work
is actually Collective uh largely
Collective morality we here in this
country have a uh judeo-christian moral
framework for the most part even the
atheists and agnostics in this country
do as I often mention Bill Maher being a
great example he may not understand why
he believes in the right of free speech
or the right to a speedy trial or a jury
of your peers and uh innocent until
proven guilty he may not understand why
he holds those values but if you study
history if you study the traditions of
the United States and where this
morality comes from and the legal system
going back to the Magna Carta Etc you'll
be like wow
these people were all very Christian and
learned these lessons from the Bible I'm
not saying you need the Bible I mean
Sheamus May disagree I'm just saying
that there's a route to where this
morality comes from and if you go to
Eastern countries like China their roots
on morality are very very different
so that brings me to the question of how
do we successfully run a country United
States when we're dealing with a
multicultural democracy and a
constitutional republic well the
Multicultural democracy is basically
breaking into our constitutional
Republican trying to supplant and
subvert it we must defend ourselves from
that and that means that if we have a
moral worldview and a moral framework
that for the most part we agree upon we
act upon that not under this guise of
codified logical legal code the the the
I come to this conclusion
because we were talking about Florida
and parental rights do does a parent
have a right to determine what medical
treatment their kids do get or do not
get do you think parents have the
absolute right
yes with very few exceptions so where
I'm from British Columbia we have a law
called the infants act which essentially
states that parental approval is not
needed for any medical procedure at any
age provided the doctor can understand
the doctor thinks it's necessary and the
doctor thinks the child can understand
and what happened a year or two ago a
father went to jail his name is Rob
Hoogland because he spoke out against
his daughter's transition which he was
powerless to stop the endocrinologist a
man named Brendan Hirsch sent him a
letter saying he could be a friend an
advisor to his own 13 year old daughter
but he couldn't stop her from receiving
testosterone
now the only Ray that law would ever
make sense for me is in the case of
maybe a Jehovah's Witness who won't
allow a blood transfusion because their
child's going to die yeah and they'll
let their child die in that case I'd say
sure intervene but in almost any other
circumstance I don't get it so the
reason I bring this up is the left's
argument is that parents should have
final say over What treatments their
kids get and that if you know the the
child wants to get a a you know a sex
change surgery or whatever that the
parents and the doctor decide the
government shouldn't intervene but
parents don't have the right to abuse
their children
and I'm not argument I'm saying the left
argues this position while
simultaneously arguing the government
should be allowed to mandate children
receive a medical treatment I.E the
vaccine conservatives have an inversion
conservatives argue the government
should stop a parent from trying to give
their children a sex change under the
arguments you just made it is it is
abusive and at the same time the
government should not be able to apply
by a mandate on a vaccine I am not
saying one idea is right or wrong what
I'm saying is there are different views
under the very similar parental rights
argument and of course we we on this
side will assert we are actually right
and we can write down the logic of that
But ultimately when it comes down to
explaining the principle of parental
rights you run into a simple question
when is where is the moral line for you
when do you say the parents are abusing
their kids and not giving them treatment
well obviously for us a child sex change
is abuse no question the left doesn't
see it that way therefore the principle
of parental rights means nothing all
that matters is the moral question that
we agree upon and if that's the case
then I believe this country should be
run on what is our Collective moral
framework and we must defend it
I just want to say one thing
I use this the expression the left all
the time it is the left we're pushing
this but it's not all the left most
leftists agree with us on this
when I was at Boston Children's Hospital
last year I had a protest there
were 200 antifa people on the other side
of the street there were about 10
parents standing with me
eight or nine of them
where lifelong Democrat voters moms
who know that they're girls or girls and
not boys now the mayor of Boston mayor
Wu said that I was a white supremacist
on a tour of Terror wow and they're
standing with me were a bunch of
lifelong Democrats the far left has
taken hostage the entire left because if
anyone on the left speaks up about any
of this they're then deemed the bigot
their anti-lgbt these four letters that
paralyze people they're kicked out of
their political parties so all the
normal leftists I say normal leftists I
don't agree with many of their
ideologies at all but the the moderate
leftists aren't allowed to say anything
it's really this 10 of the party has
taken the whole party hostage but look
here I am banging on the door of the
right wing begging to be called the
conservative but Sheamus keeps calling
me a liberal PBS guy's a liberal over
here
Sheamus has made the argument on this
show if you are pro-choice you can't be
a conservative yeah I I think that's a
weighted issue yeah I I think that you
can be a conservative and be pro-choice
that's such a fundamental issue to the
parties
in classical terms you're liberal where
yeah and where Liberty comes from the
Latin libertad meaning freedom but now
the left says the word Liberty itself is
a dog whistle for fascism that's right
not even not even the classical sense
not even the Phyllis philosophical sense
if you look up traditional liberalism or
social liberal liberalism in this
country you'll be like that actually
sounds like Tim a whole lot this is
where Democrats were for a long time so
these people you're mentioning they're
probably very much in a similar
political space to where we on this show
are yet they call this show conservative
they call me a conservative commentator
despite the fact that I argue with
conservatives all the time yeah
especially on issues like this yeah I'm
called the far right but I'm pretty
sensuous it depends on the issue well I
also think it's hilarious that you
referred to as a white supremacist not a
tour of Terror because I think they'll
just say anything they'll just say
anything no
no I've seen a bit of your work but I
haven't heard much
official politics for me how can they
even claim white supremacists is this
just because everything fits under the
alphabet soup label and so if you oppose
that stuff you're a white racist
because you're white yeah yeah so that's
it well hold on hold on brilliant so you
must be scaring me you're a supremacist
and you're white therefore get it yeah
at Portland State this
Professor he's a geology Professor he's
an Adjunct professor he came out to
counter protest us on his bike standing
right in front of us so I couldn't talk
to people and then he took his shirt off
his sweater off to reveal that he's been
on estrogen
now this guy said that we were white
supremacists and I said hold on
what what makes me a white supremacist
he said well look at you I said well
you're white
so his explanation ultimately was that
transphobia is the tip of the Spear of
white supremacy
oh yeah I was at Occupy Wall Street and
they were trying to figure out what
their main goal was going to be and
they're talking about the banks and the
corruption and then an exasperation some
guy stands up screaming at the top of
his lungs how do you people not
understand fracking is everything just
furious fracking and I'm just like yo
fracking like cuddle the Frack down okay
fracking has nothing to do with this
president getting elected and like but
this guy in his brain the only thing it
could process was fracking he thought
the president was only elected because
big oil companies were investing and
those would allow fracking and that the
reason why climate change is happening
is fracking the reason why there's
social disorder is because these big oil
companies that was the center of his
Universe it was the only thing he could
comprehend very much like this guy his
whole world is trans issues so any
argument is the most Paramount problem
the world is facing yes these leftists
would sooner have us import oil from
Saudi Arabia than produce it ourselves
yeah yeah well that's what they think
how dare you that's right I mean we
can't drill in the United States because
when we pull oil out of the ground and
burn it that's bad for the environment
but when we burn oil other people pulled
out of the ground that's good for the
environment well how about we just say
when we create completely emission free
energy nuclear yeah they also don't want
us doing that either it's almost like
they just want to neuter energy
Independence or something like that like
they don't care about our country and
want to fail thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time